[Music]
first off magformers are fun it's
magnetic construction I'm the CEO for
magformers we're toy company on December
27th we had a lot of work to do and
closing out our year a lot of happiness
early in the morning some of our toys
received awards and excitement of seeing
2018 come to an end
it was mid-morning when all of a sudden
we had two of our employees race from
different directions in the office they
both were bringing the same
communication and that is that a child
had swallowed magformers Jennifer white
thought this small piece of plastic was
a unique Christmas gift instead the
magnets inside of it left holes
throughout her son's stomach they were
doing what magnets do and try to get to
each other through his intestines and it
created holes in it in the lining the
toy that caused the injury was purchased
on Amazon The Wall Street Journal set
out to investigate how many unsafe
products like this are on Amazon's
massive marketplace the toy gifted to
the white family wasn't actually
magformers rather it was one of the many
similar looking products for sale on
Amazon by a third-party
300,000 social media hits later the
father of the child identified the
product called indem it was taken off
Amazon site it should have been unsafe
[Music]
[Music]
when Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos started the
company he decided to sell books for a
simple reason there are a lot of books
ebooks were great because books are
incredibly unusual in one respect that
is there are more items in the book
category and there are items than any
other category by far as Amazon has
grown Bezos and other top Amazon
executives have emphasised selection as
a key aspect of Amazon's business
philosophy if you can focus obsessively
enough on customer experience selection
we keep pursuing that notion of earth's
biggest selection its selection the
three big ideas are low prices fast
delivery and vast selection search
magnetic toy on Amazon and you're
presented with an avalanche of choices
colors shapes numbers of pieces price in
2001 Jeff Bezos came up with his theory
of the virtuous cycle according to
Amazon executives Bezos originally
sketched it on a napkin and adda since
become an important part of Amazon's
story so our virtuous cycle starts with
a terrific customer experience
it uses the concept of a flywheel a
heavy wheel that's hard to turn
initially but generates its own momentum
and become self-reinforcing once it gets
going in Amazon's case it goes like this
greater selection and lower prices lead
to greater customer satisfaction which
leads to more site visits which makes it
more attractive for third-party sellers
which increases selection and
simultaneously leads to lower overhead
for Amazon which lowers prices and round
and round it goes this theory was one of
the reasons why Amazon built its
marketplace which has grown to include
millions of third-party sellers in the
view of its executives more sellers
means more selection driving their
virtuous cycle they bring selection that
is really hard for us to get ourselves
and that adds to the customer experience
was probably the most surprising to most
consumers is the fact that most product
sold on Amazon are not sold by Amazon
itself what best describes Amazon is
it's a company of systems most of the
large businesses been built not only
have flywheels but there also has
systems which means they can be scaled
usually without any limits an Amazon
spokeswoman said the company's goals of
unbeatable price selection and
convenience don't come at the expense of
customer safety since Jeff Bezos made
his napkin drawing third-party sales
have grown from 6% of sales on Amazon to
nearly 60 percent and as this
marketplace has exploded in size so too
has the need to balance selection and
product safety The Wall Street Journal
conducted a search of Amazon's site for
items declared unsafe by government
agencies or that are deceptively
labelled products that big-box retailers
won't sell the journals investigation
found about 4,100 such products for sale
on Amazon and an additional six thousand
seven hundred balloons that lacked
federally mandated warning labels 83% of
the listings were updated or removed
after the journal sent Amazon the
products it identified the Food and Drug
Administration warns this sort of
sleeping mat can suffocate infants
Amazon bans them from their marketplace
but the journal found 80 for sale in the
site anyway Amazon removed all of the
infant sleep positioners the journal
identified
the challenge for Amazon is that what
build the Amazon Marketplace it being so
open and so welcoming to new sellers has
also meant that today Amazon is really
having a hard time enforcing many of its
own rules because it just physically
cannot allocate enough human power to
policeman Amy's rules within two weeks
of Amazon's removing or altering
problematic listings a hundred and
thirty items with the same policy
violations reappeared some sold by the
same vendors in Amazon spokeswoman said
it removed these items and refined its
tools for catching them she added that
the company's tools prevent most
non-compliant listings from ever
appearing on the site and when sellers
managed to evaded systems Amazon acts
quickly to remove items and penalize the
offending seller additionally she said
the company provides resources to
sellers about proper labeling and other
compliance obligations
[Music]
the marketplace was very clearly set up
to be an independent entity where people
could use the technology that Amazon a
built but not necessarily be part of
Amazon my name is Rachel Johnson Greer
and I've been working in this consulting
business that I started four years ago
we help sellers on Amazon Marketplace I
worked at Amazon for about eight years
and my first role in compliance was
handling all of recalls and product
safety for North America I got very
familiar with how Amazon enforced on
sellers how they communicated with
sellers we can say that we're not going
to interfere in the marketplace but as
soon as customers are upset or someone
could get hurt
now we have a problem in 2011 the
Consumer Product Safety Commission or
CPSC issued recalls from any drop side
cribs as the news media and public were
increasingly concerned about their
safety the largest baby crib recall in
history involves more than two million
drop side cribs the CPSC was trying to
redesign their crib regulations and all
cribs had to meet the new regulation I
believe it was by June 2011 working with
recalls normally what we would do is we
would remove everything from Amazon I
was like then let's remove all the cribs
and then anything that comes back is
guaranteed to be compliant I was told
that they didn't want to take things
down because it would limit selection
that's what they're incentivized to do
more selection more sales
as a compliance person you're
incentivized to either meet the law or
protect customers and those two did not
go together at the time I was about six
months pregnant and what I argued to
them was that no mother no mother ever
wants selection that's going to hurt her
child ever and I lost the argument and
that has that has been painful ever
since in Amazon spokeswoman said the
company executes recalls as soon as it
is aware of them and requires sellers to
meet any new requirements the CPSC
introduces what does it take to ensure a
safe children's product The Wall Street
Journal ordered a selection of
children's toys that are popular on
Amazon and sent them to a federally
certified lab for testing
they were subjected to drop tests torque
tests chemical tests and more
of the ten toys the journal sent for
testing for failed one of those was this
xylophone from the I Luke II toddler
musical instrument set which was found
to contain four times the federal limit
of lead for children the company
disputed the results and sent a test
report from a different laboratories
showing a passing result the journal
spoke to safety and compliance experts
who said this discrepancy should trigger
a halt to sales and more testing and
Amazon removed these items from their
marketplace government officials are
also turning their attentions to the
dangers posed by some products sold on
Amazon so we're here to announce today
that Amazon will commit to legally
binding nationwide corporate reforms
after my office found dozens of
children's school supplies and jewelry
sold on its marketplace had illegal
levels of toxic metals we just had some
suspicions that there were products out
there for sale that had not been
adequately tested and were not compliant
with the law and not safe for children
we tested about a hundred Amazon
products more than half had illegal
amounts of lead and cadmium it's not a
great track record to start with kids
with their toys with their school
supplies if they're anything like my
kids when they were young they're
chewing on those things they're sleeping
with them they are in close proximity
often for many hours a day across the
country consumers made more than 15,000
purchases of these products so it led to
a settlement Amazon this case has to say
the state make consumers whole for what
they pay for most importantly change the
corporate practices and detail what that
looks like an Amazon spokeswoman said
the company welcomes ongoing
collaboration with the Attorney General
to promote customer safety the only real
way to know as Amazon but the products
that are being sold on the website are
compliant is to pull it from the
fulfillment center send it to a lab
themselves and get it tested because
otherwise paperwork is paperwork you can
just make up whatever you want
not only are there a lot of unsafe
products on Amazon many of them sold by
third parties imitates safe popular
items
I wasn't Marketplace means anyone can
sell anything which also means if you're
a bad actor trying to sell an unsafe
product the counterfeit products a
wrongly named product you can a lot of
the work rooting out bad sellers on
amazon's marketplace is done not by
amazon but by other sellers our binder
against counterfeit has been going on
since 2012 I mean how many times have
some of these changed from one name to
another on Amazon oh they they tend to
change very quickly
or they're sold under various names
which one is ours
these two are ours these two are
counterfeit there is almost no real
distinction between the packaging so
when mom and dad get at home they won't
know that something's amiss and that's
our biggest concern we are showing you
how easy it is to break one of the
knockoffs and these magnets are not
something you want laying around your
house if you have small children or pets
in Amazon spokeswoman said the company
investigates claims and takes action
against bad actors
she said Amazon also gives sellers tools
to remove unsafe selection and
counterfeit items
she added in the case of Emden magnetic
toy blocks Amazon removed the item as
soon as it became aware of the safety
incident
the manufacturer of Emden magnetic
building blocks declined to comment
amazon has gotten so big and does so
many things that many ask what is Amazon
Bezos himself has been asked this
question what is Amazon I would say
really it's a collection of principles
and it's an approach that we deploy but
if these principles conflict with safety
will they have to change the things that
they claim to be impossible are just
ultimately the most you could argue that
many of these issues can and will be
solved by Amazon both will probably
require fundamentally changing the
building blocks
I believe the amazon has the ability to
do anything they want they're the
strongest and most powerful retailer at
this point in the world I in fact
actually don't buy from third-party
sellers for my son because I know that
there's a risk there I will buy from
well-known brands and I will pay the
extra because I know what I'm paying for
a lot of consumers don't or they don't
have the resources to make that choice
I'm under no illusion that somehow our
agreement Amazon is solving the problem
by any stretch of the imagination but do
we want to communicate to Amazon hey
we're watching yes you don't get it
passed and because it's really big and
it's really complicated
you
[Music]